[Music]
from the media from the schools from the
politicians all we ever hear these days
is how important it is to encourage
people to transition their gender when
they feel the inkling that they ought to
transition their gender doesn't matter
what age they are doesn't matter what
other issues are going on in their lives
doesn't matter if the children are
children or really little children
if a little boy says i i am really a
little girl or a little girl says i am
really a little boy the
new prevailing consensus is we must put
them on chemicals possibly put them
through surgery stop puberty
try to reverse puberty there is no
stopping that
as a result some people who have had
these kinds of procedures pushed upon
them or who have engaged in them
apparently willingly have wanted to
reverse them and you're seeing this
trend spike up now even as the laws in
some places make it illegal to prevent
kids from going through these processes
one of the people who has
transitioned
and detransitioned is helena kirschner
helena kirschner is a 23 year old
de-transitioned woman
she began to
transition
shortly after her 18th birthday and has
now
transitioned back quite an odyssey
uh helena thank you so much for coming
on the show thank you very much for
having me
so i we don't have a ton of time i wish
we could speak for four or five hours i
have about a thousand questions for you
so i'll start at the very beginning
what was it
right after your 18th birthday or i
imagine in the years before that
that that made you think that you were a
boy or what is it is it the case that
you thought you were a boy or you you
thought that you were
a trans boy you know not quite a boy but
something different and certainly not a
woman
yeah absolutely so for me it wasn't just
like one moment where i woke up and i
said i'm a boy um actually as a child i
wasn't very atypical
in like a gender sense um i you know i i
liked girly clothes i had no problem
with it i had no problem with girl
toys um so it's never an issue for me
but what really kind of changed that for
me was around the time i was 15 years
old
i was going through a period in my life
where i just didn't have a lot of
friends um i was having body
insecurities that were just really kind
of tormenting me um and this led me to
go online a lot i kind of stopped having
friends in the real world i stopped
really engaging in school and i turned
to internet communities that allowed me
to
discuss some of my interests and my
passions with other young girls
and in these internet communities
for me that was a website called tumblr
it's very the the gender ideology is
very prominent there and as kind of a
prerequisite to being able to
participate in those social communities
you have to really agree with the gender
ideology and
there's a lot of social incentives to do
something like um change your pronouns
from a she her to a they them that's a
very small step that isn't an instant
commitment to like becoming a boy or
transitioning so that's how it started
for me i felt that kind of social
pressure and so i did start to change my
pronouns
and it took two or three years before i
actually reached that place where i was
like i'm a boy and it was this feedback
loop of getting that positive response
from the other people online every time
i would do something that was moving
towards changing my gender
that led me to over the course of those
years kind of self-indoctrinate
um into thinking that i was a boy
it's so frightening because what you're
describing
you were 15 years old you felt socially
awkward you had body issues
i think that describes every single 15
year old certainly every six 15 year old
girl
and so you've got this totally common
issue and and it wasn't even that you
were
uh
indoctrinated into this ideology at the
mall with your friends or in the
classroom even it was
the internet it was this you know there
was this portal
in in your room or on your phone and and
in order to be accepted in these
communities and to participate in these
communities
you had to participate in this ideology
absolutely the ideology is so prevalent
and something that i think a lot of you
know older generations don't quite
understand is that
in the perspective of that 15 year old
girl who
has had a falling out with her friends
she feels lonely she feels insecure
those internet communities that they
then find that feel so accepting to them
they feel like the be all and end all
it's not just something you're casually
kind of browsing to get updates about
your favorite show or celebrity it's
like these internet communities are you
know they're what what makes you feel
accepted and they're where you want to
fit in so you're willing to do almost
anything to kind of conform to that
social group and it's not necessarily a
conscious thing where you're saying oh
i'm going to change my gender so that
i'll fit in but it's like you you have
all of these kind of subconscious
motivations that are saying you know
um and also things that are very overt i
mean there are
people in these communities who will say
if you don't like your body that's a
sign of gender dysphoria if you don't
fit in with other girls that's a sign of
gender dysphoria if you don't like the
way your voice sounds in a recording
that's a sign of gender dysphoria i have
to pause you there if you don't like the
what that's real not one single person
on earth likes the way their voice
sounds in a recording that's
that's a universal experience
exactly so you have these messages that
as a teenager you don't really realize
how universal it is but you have these
these people in these posts and and
everything telling you that these are
all signs of gender dysphoria and so you
have that these these subconscious
motivations and you also have that overt
kind of
brainwashing that happens that
encourages encourages you to reinterpret
everything in your life as a sign of
gender dysphoria so the reinterpretation
i think is really interesting did you
grow up with
a particularly solid
world view you know were you raised
christian or were you raised with some
particular political view or or or not
um so i wasn't really raised christian
although i did attend a catholic school
my parents kind of lean conservative and
they were always suspicious of public
schools so i did start out going to a
catholic school though we weren't really
practicing in any way um and as for
any kind of political view
i think i vaguely just tried to copy
what my parents were talking about but
it obviously as a child like you're not
the one really having those views so
then i i really didn't have like any
kind of stable
value system so then when i was able to
go into these online communities
unsupervised without the adults in my
life kind of checking in like what is it
you're doing on your computer for all
those hours then i was just really
vulnerable to internalizing these
messages and these political
views that are
in these online spaces and one of the
things that's so alluring about them is
you know i think every teenager
goes through a period where they want to
kind of differentiate from their parents
they want to say oh mom and dad are you
know you know old-fashioned they're
outdated blah blah blah that's pretty
natural but this kind of political world
view that you find in these online
communities it turns that feeling that
you have of oh my parents suck into like
a radical political thing it makes it
feel so validated so important so that's
also another reason why it just really
appealed to me to adopt beliefs about
gender and race and sexuality um that my
family didn't have right so so you're in
this world for two years three years
at a certain point you say i am a boy
and i'm going to transition to be a boy
can you i'm not even sure that you would
have been conscious of this really or
aware of it but
what
what did that look like i mean no matter
how gradual the process is to actually
come out one day and say i am a boy what
what was going on in your mind to to
make you think that you were a boy
um it's
it's a lot to unpack i mean it's it's
something that's very heavily influenced
by
fantasy by being constantly plugged into
this kind of alternate reality that
doesn't have a lot of basis in the
physical world
um so it's it's a lot of talking to
other peers who are very creative
they're imagining these ideas they're
imagining these what their future is
going to look like and just not really
having any pushback against that from
any of your peers and so that just very
easily i feel spirals out of control
and there's also this element of you
know
when you are using social media and
you're constantly scrolling it all day
you're just getting message after
message after picture after idea kind of
seeping into your mind and when you
don't have those good you know stable
relationships outside of the internet
it's really easy for that to all go in
question so you can begin to form
beliefs that don't stand up to scrutiny
and would easily kind of fall apart if
you were to verbalize them to someone
who is actually
critical of those ideas but engaging you
in a in a compassionate way
you're able to just carry those ideas
with you and make decisions based off of
them when in reality the ideas
themselves like they don't make sense
they're not founded in reality so for me
it was it was a lot of stuff just based
on
fantasy based on
literally just pictures that i was
seeing all the time of cute boys and
then these messages that were saying you
know your life is going to be so much
better if you transition you are trans
the reason you don't fit in with other
girls is because you're trans so it's
really this
stew this this big complicated stew of
unreality that
young people fall into when they're just
scrolling all day on social media
and don't have
pushback really that technological point
had not totally occurred to me that is
such an insightful point
when kids go outside and they play
superheroes and you're going to be
superman and you're going to be batman
and you play around but
you never fly you can't fly because when
you're playing around outside you are
tethered to the physical world but when
you're scrolling when you're online
there is basically no connection to the
physical world now we're talking about
the metaverse you know facebook is
creating this true virtual reality that
people are going to live in
there is no reason why a boy couldn't be
a girl and a girl couldn't be a boy the
physical doesn't really matter that's a
really really insightful point so you
you go into tumblr
you spend your whole day scrolling there
you're
being inundated with these messages and
these images telling you your life's
gonna be better if you're a boy you
decide okay i'm gonna transition
you're 18 years old 18 in a couple of
days
what is the reaction
um from people in my life your family
any friends you you said you didn't have
really friends outside of the the
internet but the reaction online i had a
very yeah i had a small group of friends
but they were all also using
this website tumblr so it was still like
our friendship was very mediated weirdly
through the social media that we were
using um but yeah my parents definitely
um i told my mom about my intention to
transition and she understandably did
not take it well
um but our relationship was already
already a bit strained at that point so
um i just don't feel like we were
communicating very effectively and her
response which was really a lot of um
anger that actually made me a little bit
more resistant it made me more steadfast
in my conviction that being trans was
the right thing so um
yes i
about two weeks after my 18th birthday i
did make an appointment at a planned
parenthood clinic because at the time
there wasn't as many clinics as there
are now um so i had to actually travel
to another state to go to a planned
parenthood because they were one of the
only ones offering this informed consent
model which is really the easiest way to
get hormones
so you went into planned parenthood you
said i am identifying as a boy i think
that i'm a boy
did they say okay well you've got to go
talk to some therapists for some period
of months or years or did they say here
are the pills lady go hear the pills sir
go go have a good day
pretty much here it's not even pills
it's injections um here are the
injections sir um so
yeah my appointment took about an hour
um the first maybe 20 minutes or so was
a short back and forth between my the
social worker that i met at the planned
parenthood and actually if you read my
sub stack piece i wrote a sub stack
piece about basically my whole journey
um i show
these questions that the social worker
asked me in their their uh it's not deep
psychological work to say the least yeah
um so i had this short
uh interview intake process with the
social worker
and then she you know came back in and
said you're the perfect candidate for
testosterone let's get you started and
so i moved on to the nurse practitioner
and the nurse practitioner went over a
very short list of risks with me um that
were very understated it said things
like you may have mood issues which is
like that's not a way to properly convey
the possibilities of of hormonal
treatment but anyway so i looked over
this short list and so and then we
started talking about the dosage
and typically when
you know when you start a regimen of
anything they start you on a lower
dosage and then if it's decided that you
need to go on a higher dosage then you
will gradually move up
and so that's what she suggested to me
and i being my very confused teenage
self i told her that i think i'm going
to need a higher dose because i think i
have more estrogen
because i have wider hips
and the nurse practitioner just did not
question this at all and she said okay
so how much would you like
and it's like a drug i said
just like you go to a drug dealer you
know some of my uh more derelict friends
they'll go to their their drug dealer
you see this with really uh
you know kind of like this woman i guess
questionable dubious psychiatrists where
they'll say okay i'm going to give you x
amount of adderall and then you know a
junkie will say no i'd like three times
that actually and they say okay no big
deal so this this woman just goes along
with an 18 year old girl confused about
her sex says yeah okay how many
milligrams do you want
and i say you know what's the highest we
can go and she says 100 milligrams is
usually the highest we do and if you
look at kind of the the guidelines
various universities and health systems
they have guidelines and 100 milligrams
is usually the maximum dosage and so
that's what i started on right out the
gate as an 18 year old girl was 100
milligrams of testosterone as an
injection so you you start taking the
testosterone
what does it do i mean what does that
feel like
so
at first the biggest changes were kind
of what you would expect although
being myself in my mind at the time i
didn't make the connection i just didn't
understand what was happening to me it
was very disorienting but the first kind
of symptoms was just more irritability
um i just felt kind of
antsy like little things would bother me
things people would say would just kind
of set me off i noticed that my my
temper was a little bit more out of
control i would snap at people more
easily i didn't really want to be around
people all that much because i just
didn't feel like myself again i felt so
disoriented so i started isolating a lot
more um and then obviously the other
obvious effect is like that higher sex
drive which for me as a young girl who i
feel like before testosterone i had a
fairly average you know female sex drive
experience
it just really went through the roof and
it was i felt
really out of control i felt really
overwhelmed it was not a pleasant
experience um so that's kind of where it
started out which i think
is somewhat to be expected but my
experience took maybe an unexpected turn
possibly because i was on such a high
dose although
there's no answers i still have never
really been able to get answers for some
of these things um where
that anger would get so intense i would
have like such overwhelming rage attacks
that i actually would end up hurting
myself instead of hurting others because
i was just so out of control i couldn't
control myself i felt like a monster
and so that was definitely
the
the biggest consequence for me and i
kind of i dealt with that maybe once or
twice a week
or a little bit less at some times um
for a few months and it eventually got
so bad where i had to be
hospitalized when when you say you were
hurting yourself you're not saying you
went into a fit of rage and fell off the
bed you're saying you're you were
actively taking a conscious sort of
decision to perform
yeah it was um it's
a very difficult
experience to describe but
um
i guess before i was on testosterone
when i would have a really strong
emotion
it might move me to tears and i would
just cry and sob but while i was on
testosterone i lost the ability to cry
very easily so i would get that intense
emotion but there would be no outlet and
then for one reason or another that
would trigger anger i would get so angry
and frustrated
and that anger was just so overwhelming
and i got the urge to really externalize
it i got the urge to
hit things or or throw things i just
didn't want to do that i felt so out of
control that i would just kind of take
it out on myself to calm myself down and
to be an outlet for that rage because i
didn't know how else to handle it i was
completely overwhelmed and so during
this period i
no need to answer if you feel i'm crying
too much but as you were
transitioning your sex did you did you
feel you had a transition of your
sexual desire were you you say you had
this very high sex drive were you
were you attracted to boys or girls
um i've always like you know primarily
been attracted to boys but
honestly like
one of the things that was so
overwhelming about like this like
increased sex drive was the fact that
just like
visual things
were more easily arousing so i might see
like a photo of a provocatively dressed
woman and my brain would almost like
register that as like oh that's a sexual
thing you're gonna interpret that as
sexual but i wasn't really seeking out
relationships with women or anything but
yeah it was uh
that was a really interesting
experience ever since quitting
testosterone i've lost all that i just
am attracted to men now but yeah so you
so you're in this this sounds really
like hell you're already a
confused teenager you now are
hyper-sexualized
hyper-filled with rage
and this goes on for
this goes on for how long before you
decide hey maybe i'm not actually a boy
um
so that went on for a few months and i
talked about in my piece about how i
actually needed to be hospitalized twice
due to this
um and sometime after and just as a side
note
not once in either of my
hospitalizations or any of my mental
health treatment that i was receiving
because of these extreme symptoms was
the testosterone ever mentioned that was
never brought up like i would write down
you know i'm a biological female f and
i'm on 100 milligrams a week of
testosterone
but none of these psychiatrists and none
of these nurses and none of these
doctors ever mentioned that testosterone
as possibly a reason for my experience i
was just diagnosed with a bunch of
different things and prescribed a bunch
of different psych meds and just kind of
sent on my way um so it took me
kind of
skipping testosterone doses because i
was developing an anxiety of the needle
so i started skipping my doses and as i
started taking the testosterone less
my
crazy insane symptoms started going away
and so that was one of the things that
kind of clued me in to like huh okay
well maybe i'm not just like a mentally
ill crazy person maybe it's the
testosterone so i started kind of
scaling back on that and then
around this time i was doing a lot of
reflecting on you know
this is not matching up to that fantasy
i had as a teenager as a teenager i was
kind of promised you know like this is
going to save your life this is going to
make you feel authentic this is going to
make you your true self this is gonna
make you so happy um you see all this
stuff like you know it's trans joy like
all this kind of like really frilly
happy positive language
that's not what happened to me
so i really started kind of comparing
my reality versus my expectations before
i transitioned
and eventually that led me to
just fully realize that it was all a
total mistake and i i realized very
quickly
that
i was just really confused and this
whole trans thing was not real for me i
i just can't get over
the medical malpractice of you get a
patient like you comes into the doctor
the doctor says okay well this young
girl is taking an insane amount of
testosterone injecting it into her every
single day yeah maybe cut back on the
coca-colas and you'll feel better oh
maybe we should ply her with more drugs
that'll that'll fix it it
couldn't possibly have anything to do
with this totally unnatural experimental
medical procedure that we've only been
doing for like five minutes that is so
insanely irresponsible that if you
weren't saying it to my face right now i
wouldn't believe it i know and it's
almost hard for me to believe but it's
like think about it it's not just one
doctor who did that either it's multiple
doctors multiple nurses multiple
therapists that i met throughout
two hospitalizations and just multiple
mental health programs and none of them
ever brought up the testosterone or
questioned my
trans
status whatsoever that's true truly
insane probably they feared they'd lose
their license if they ever made any
mention of this it's so politically
incorrect so so you on your own with no
help from these useless doctors you on
your own realize huh when i inject the
testosterone less and less i the
symptoms abate
how old are you at at this point so at
that point i was about 19 19 and a half
okay so
do you then come to the conclusion okay
i've got to stop this i've you know the
fantasy isn't matching up i i've got to
go back to being a girl so that this
would have been a little little before
you turned 20.
yeah about six months before i turned 20
i just had this like breakthrough moment
of like
holy cow
this is insane it's really weird when i
think back to it it's like one moment i
was kind of under the spell in this
delusion and then the next moment it was
like this the dormant like rational me
inside of me woke up and was like holy
how this is totally insane
why am i trying to be a boy yeah
right right it seems so simple but if
you're in the throes of it you know
maybe it's not so
so at that point you just throw out the
testosterone or do you go to a doctor
and sort of change your
classification or what happens no
yeah i mostly just stopped taking the
testosterone i threw it all out i was
really like disgusted by it i just
wanted it out of my sight i wanted it
out of my living space um and i
went to
this clinic that i had been going to and
i did tell them that i stopped the
testosterone but they didn't ask why um
and i felt too
ashamed and embarrassed to to tell them
because at that point i really thought
that i was the only person on earth who
had ever regretted transitioning um that
was never
a concept in my mind all i thought was
trans is awesome trans is amazing life
is going to be awesome
and so i just i felt so embarrassed so i
didn't say anything to those clinicians
because i knew that there i mean this
was a clinic in chicago with like black
lives matter and trans rights our human
rights like splattered all over their
clinic
where all the clinicians were
transgender too so
um i was i was very scared to say
anything about my regrets to them
because i knew how
people had treated the idea of regret in
the trans community which is
not in a nice way no no is it uh
denial that people really do have regret
or is it just outright hostility um it
can be both so it's denial that regret
ever happens you know you see these like
kind of statistics thrown around that
are really they're not relevant to the
situation at hand where it's like oh
only zero zero zero like point zero zero
zero one percent of people regret
transitioning
no
um so you see that kind of denial and
then you also get that hostility where
it's like oh well you're just stupid
you're just you know everyone else is
trans but you're just an idiot um where
it's like they really turn on you where
it's like when you are that 15 year old
16 year old um saying that oh does this
mean i'm trans like yes that means
you're trans you're so trans you you
need to like you need to question
yourself more you need to change your
pronouns you need to get a binder you
need to do this i'll buy you a binder
all these people and then as soon as you
regret it they're like oh you're an
idiot could you forgive my what is a
binder
oh it's a chest compression thing so
when i was on tumblr some uh and
actually an older adult person on tumblr
bought me a chest compressor when i was
about 15 or 16.
man
so okay so you
you go you
say okay i'm not doing this anymore i
put i put the testosterone away
you seem
you seem great you seem uh you know sort
of back to normal uh have you had long
lasting effects from these years i guess
luckily it was only a couple of years or
so on this testosterone it doesn't sound
like you did any further procedures that
might have been harder to reverse are
you dealing with long long term effects
um i have been really fortunate in that
i haven't had any long-term health
effects which is
not something that many people can say
many people even after maybe only two
years on testosterone like they're still
dealing with very permanent effects and
sometimes it can be dangerous health
effects too um but i have been really
fortunate for me the hardest part has
been kind of
the psychological aspect of feeling like
like i was really indoctrinated and i
was really led down a bad path by
um just
people that that i didn't know and that
didn't know me and were just encouraging
me to make these decisions i mean
telling me that life would be so amazing
and
that's been really hard to kind of
come back from and also just
other than the the
transitioning in and of itself i made a
lot of decisions at that young age
chasing this fantasy that were really
not good for my life um and so kind of
it's been just like digging myself out
of this hole that i dug for myself at a
really young age but now thankfully you
know some years after i'm really like
doing a lot better and i'm just kind of
focusing on
telling my story so that people can
understand better what's going on
because a lot of people just really
aren't aware about so many of these
things that we're talking about today
what do you mean you sort of made
decisions for your life
that you're digging out of now beyond
the obviously the physical you're
shooting yourself up with testosterone
what what other if you don't mind
sharing what other sort of decisions
yeah
there's kind of this
common dynamic in the trans community
where it's like if your parents don't
completely
agree with your being trans and you're
transitioning that they're evil and
they're
horrible and you need to cut them out of
your life and so
i actually did do that for a period of
time where i just completely stopped
talking to my family
and um on the one hand i feel like i
really hurt my brother and that way i
have a little brother and i think like
he really needed his sister during some
of those periods and i just wasn't there
because i was
chasing this pipe dream and then on the
other hand um while i was kind of
disengaged with my family my grandma
developed alzheimer's and
by the time i was able to reconnect with
them
she was basically gone so
that's been one of the most difficult
things to cope with um just just in my
in this like haze of chasing this false
identity and this ideological
thing
um i gave up one of these really
important relationships in my life um so
yeah that's been really difficult so
that's that's that is that is hard and
it's it is a reminder everybody not just
people who
go down this kind of crazy rabbit hole
which you're describing as being quite
cultish right cut off all your family
and you know pursue this very sort of
radical view of human nature and fantasy
but
but everyone to some degree you know
does
deals with these things where oh if i
had
not been so focused on this one thing i
could have i should have done this
differently i could you know this this
really set me back a number of years so
now that this is being debated
not just for 18 year olds by the way but
for eight-year-olds for five-year-olds
there's a big fight over a law in
florida that says you can't talk about
transgenderism in a kindergarten
classroom and and the white house is
saying this is horrible and abusive and
of course we need to talk about
transgenderism to toddlers
what is your advice for parents who
who might be dealing with this with
their own kids now or in the very near
future
so um
for parents who aren't dealing with it
quite yet um
i think one really important thing is to
you know recognize that social media is
very dangerous and these devices that
kids are using are very dangerous
because they don't have you know adult
level rational cognitive faculties and
even many adults are not really able to
moderate and and think critically when
interacting with some of these platforms
so one thing i kind of ask parents to
think about is
when your child wants to go for a
sleepover you ask them who is this
friend how did you meet who is their mom
where do they live what is her phone
number uh you maybe even want to meet
the parents and go to coffee with them
and get to know them but when your
child's been sitting on their phone for
six hours straight you have no idea
where they are
and who they're talking to
um and kind of going with that i think a
lot of parents you know reflexively
think that the solution is to just ban
all social media
and while i think that's really well
intended
these kids are more
intuitively able to get around that
they're better at using social media
than you are they will get around it so
just like um to protect your kids from
someone in the real world you wouldn't
ban them from ever talking to anybody
period you would talk to them about who
their friends are and get to know
what they're doing and what they're
thinking about and who they're friends
with um you should approach social media
in a similar way get to know like
especially if they're still young um
just get to know what they're doing what
they're interested in learn about what
how they're spending their time because
when they are on these devices like
that's still
time spent that's still
information learned that's still
conversations had with people who you
don't know who they are so i really
encourage parents to focus on that
communication and really um
understanding what their kids are doing
on their devices
um as for parents who may be going
through a child who already is
identifying as trans and you know you
know in your gut that it's just not the
right thing um
i would recommend checking out an
organization that i'm a part of it's
called genspect that's g-e-n-s-p-e-c-t
it's basically a um organization that
advocates for parents and has all sorts
of groups where parents can talk and be
advised on how best to navigate your
relationship with this
um
this kind of crisis that is fomenting so
yeah i highly recommend genspect and
getting involved in parent communities
and learning about the better ways to
manage this because um it's always
better to be informed
that that analogy you just made of the
sleepover i haven't heard that before
that's such an apt analogy because
obviously you wouldn't you wouldn't send
your kid to a sleepover where you have
no idea who the kid's
sleeping with you have no idea where the
kid is going and yet when you send your
kid up to his room and he's got a
smartphone or a laptop or a tablet or
something at 10 o'clock at night and
he's scrolling on tumblr or
whatever social media device talking to
god knows who
you are sending your kid to a sleepover
there is really no difference it's just
one one is taking place in virtual
reality which can indoctrinate them into
ideologies
that are virtual reality
like if imagine if your 12 year old
child asked if they could go to an a
meet up with people from
china
like it's like would you just let them
board that plane and go without asking
anything about it or would you like
really try to understand what was going
on yeah
wow
an amazing story helena thank you so
much for coming on uh where where else
can people find you um i am on twitter
um and sub stack both are under the same
name um it's pronounced lacroix like the
drink um but the last three letters
instead of an x are a c s z um that's a
little bit difficult maybe you can put
it in the show notes or something but um
yeah you can find me on twitter and on
substance wonderful i really encourage
people to head over there i loved that
that essay you put up on substack i'll
have to take a look at your other
writing as well really wonderful stuff
helena kirschner thank you so much for
coming on
thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
you